Khloe Kardashian and Tristan Thompson
seemingly on good terms it's such a
beautiful thing in a celebratory
birthday shout out the star Praises her
ex on Instagram but I think you just
re-evaluate things the two share
four-year-old true and eight-month-old
son whose name has yet to be revealed
the kiddos appeared in a carousel of
pigs alongside Coco's lengthy message
where she called Tristan the best father
brother and Uncle that's what everyone
says she raved over the way he's shown
up for The Littles in their family
adding quote my birthday wish for you is
that you continue to Crave change
healing and transformation I think
working on your personal growth
internally is something that will be a
forever
um Mission Chloe ended her post with a
mention to Tristan's mom Andrea who died
in January advising the NBA star to
continue making your soul and your mommy
proud
Tristan's mom
is here with us today Andrea
happy and excited for my daughter oh I
don't have a daughter
but um
when I'm when I'm texting Chloe I always
put to my daughter ladies and gentlemen
I think also motherhood just puts life
into perspective and what's important to
you
et's recently learned Chloe's been
spending time with Tristan since the
loss of his mother it's okay to spend
time with my family a store sells E.T
Chloe's acting as an amazing support
system to Tristan and making sure he
doesn't feel alone you just get through
it and now that the former couple is
getting more time together it's also
allowing them to focus on raising their
children my favorite part about being a
mom I mean it's so corny but it's just
like no matter how tired you are
whatever you just it's complete Bliss
ET Source reveals the pair is happy as
they continue navigating co-parenting
it's hard work for all parties I think
we come from a family where we believe
in that and you share children with
people and that's how it should be and I
think everyone has to handle their
co-parenting situation in their own
style it's a beautiful thing to get
along with each other and for your kids
to see that
foreign